[Musique]
bonjour
bonjour bienvenue au vist du théâtre à
Montini je vous en prie après vous passe
devant et je vous laisse
passer bienvenue donc àtini bretonux ici
au au bistre du théâtre à Montini une
émission qui permet de parler aussi du
parcours des élus en plus des des
questions d'actualité vous êtes donc
conseiller régional d'Île-de-France élu
du Parti radical gauche vous avez été le
le maire de carrière souspoissie
aujourd'hui chef de fil de l'opposition
et depuis peu conseiller spécial aussi
de la ministre de la Fonction publique
anque Gérardin beaucoup de mandat vous
avez encore du temps oui ouion c'est une
question d'organisation et puis
d'articulation avec la vie privée mais
c'est un choix personnel on va commencer
par une première question autour de de
l'actualité au conseil régional Valérie
PCR cette la nouvelle responsable la
nouvelle présidente de cette région
franilienne a commandé un audit à son
arrivé les premières conclusions sont
déjà arrivées des audits sur la
présidence socialiste première
conclusion dégradation financière
significative augmentation du nombre
d'agents au siège hausse des subventions
aux associations le tableau est plutôt
noir quelle est votre réaction sachant
que vous avez siégé par le passé dans la
majorité au côté de Jean-Paul hon alors
il s'agit tout d'abord non pas d'un
audit mais d'un avis donné par un
cabinet conseil d'une démarche initiée
par la présidente de la région elle-même
sans démarche contradictoire donc nous
on pose la question de la
sincérité peut pas l're puisque déjà
nous l'avons découvert dans la presse il
nous a été adressé que dans l'après-midi
sans possibilité d'en débattre et
aujourd'hui il sert de justification à
toutes les réductions drastiqu et
systématiqu qui sont faites sur les
budgets de fonctionnement donc on
considère que la démarche n'est pas très
réglo et on souhaite véritablement un
audit et un véritable audit
contradictoire mais on se demande si
vraiment la présidente souhait fairpl
dans ce dans cet exercice là au moment
où nous enregistrons cette émission se
déroule les discussions autour du budget
pour la région comment se passe ces
différentes discussions et plus
globalement quel bilan vous faites dans
l' opposition aujourd'hui des des
premiers mois de présidence de Valérie
PC moi j'ai la chance de présider un
groupe aujourd'hui dans l'opposition
comme j'en avais présidé un dans la
majorité il y a peu donc on a la chance
d'échanger régulièrement avec la
présidente elle je dirais décline son
programme et bien évidemment nous
partageons pas les orientations qui sont
mises en œuvre néanmoins on constate
quand même une politique de
déconstruction sociale citoyenne
économique et environnementale qui nous
déplaît car il y a une véritable
idéologie qui est derrière tout cela et
et si elle peut-être sympathique
aujourd'hui son projet politique nous le
considérons comme dangereux pour
l'île-defance il n'y avait pas de
dysfonctionnement par le passé parce
qu'on entend souvent revenir encore
aujourd'hui on l' entendu pendant la
campagne on l'entend encore aujourd'hui
j'en pense à cette audite mais en tout
cas ces avis dont on parlait il y a
quelques instants est-ce qu' avait pas
eu aussi par le passé quelques
dysfonctionnement la région des choses à
reprendre et à remettre à plat si nous
avions mené parfaitement l'exercice qui
nous avait été confié nous serions
encore en responsabilité aujourd'hui les
électeurs ont décidé de confier la
responsabilité de la région à une
nouvelle majorité donc ça c'est un fait
démocratique qui n'a pas à être mis en
cause les voies de perfectionnement
avaient été identifié j'étais en charge
de la modernisation de l'action publique
régionale sur le secteur des
associations un dispositif spécifique de
contrôle d'évaluation était en
expérimentation et pour revenir sur
l'avis justement cet avis d'ignon n'a
auditionné que 28 associations sur
plusieurs milliers qui sont
subventionnés par la région-defrance
donc il y a quand même un petit un petit
souci aujourd'hui dans la je dirais
crédibilité de cet audit même si on
enenlève rien aux qualités des
consultants de cabinet si on revient
quelques mois en arrière la candidature
de Claude Bartelone justement est-ce que
c'était une erreur c'est le candidat qui
a été désigné par le Parti socialiste
vous saviez que j'étais très proche de
jean-pa Luchon ancien président en
exercice j'aurais souhaité qu'il puisse
poursuivre peut-être en prenant en
compte un certain nombre d'éléments
nouveaux dans la façon de faire de la
politique et je crois qu'il souhaitait
aussi mettre en avant une nouvelle
génération et aujourd'hui le résultat
des urnes est celui-là moi je cherche
pas à
savoirm Sihui voà peut-être qu'il aurait
fallu qu'il soit moi je vous dis en
toute honnêteté présent à la première
séance je l'urais souhaité d'autres
considérraent que c'était une façon de
reconstruire une nouvelle opposition et
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui elle se
reconstruit en bonne intelligence avec
Carlos Da Silva président du groupe
socialiste l MZ du front Go Mounir
Satouri des écologistes et moi-même pour
le groupe radical citoyen démocrate et
écologiste et on mène aujourd'hui un
vrai travail de reconstruction puis ça
nous permet aussi de nous remettre en
question et puis de redéfinir des lignes
de combat aujourd'hui on va continuer à
parler de l'actualité locale nationale
avec vous et puis votre parcours aussi
c'est le but de ce café politique je
vous laisse passer en salle allez-y
[Musique]
eddieit élu de gauche donc élu PRG
invité aujourd'hui du café politique le
parti radical gauche justement qu'est-ce
qui vous a motivé pour arriver dans
cette dans cette formation très
clairement pourquoi celui-ci et pourquoi
pas le Parti socialiste par exemple
parce que j'étais profondément
fédéraliste européen j'étais très
attaché aussi à l'histoire de la
construction de la République et qui est
le plus vieux parti de France puisil a
été créé en
reflétait cet engagement qui était
important pour moi donc en janvier 98
j'ai décidé de rejoindre le PRG
l'origine de cet engagement il y avait
une tradition dans la famille
d'engagement politique ou pas du tout
non pas du tout c'était mes études
d'histoire l'intérêt pour le droit
constitutionnel la science politique
puis l'envie je dirais B à ses bateaux
de faire des choses et et je crois que
ça s'est présenté tout naturellement
aujourd'hui le PRG est malgré tout dans
dans l'ombre du Parti socialiste c'est
très souvent un allié du Parti
socialiste qu'est-ce qui fait la
différence fondamentale est-ce qu'un
jour on pourrait imaginer que la la
formation se détache complètement du
Parti socialiste alors nous sommes d'un
point de vue formel détaché seulement
nous favorisons le rassemblement à
gauche qui passe pour nous d'abord par
un lien privilégié avec le Parti
socialiste néanmoins nous ne sommes pas
des socialistes nous sommes des libéraux
de gauche attachés au libéralisme
économique aux libertés individuelles et
surtout à la place centrale que
l'individu peut occuper quelle est la
responsabilité de chacun et non pas je
dirais les notions de classe les notions
plutôt lié au au au collectif au
collectivisme nous sommes vraiment dans
la valorisation de l'individu et du
droit de chacun à pouvoir agir
aujourd'hui quelle réflexion quel regard
vous avez sur le Parti socialiste et
plus globalement sur sur la gauche on
entend souvent parler d'une pourquoi pas
une nouvelle formation politique à
gauche que les choses soient plus
clarifiées entre le socialisme le
libéralisme les sociodémocrate
aujourd'hui c'est un peu confus je
serais pas très honnête si je ne vous
disais pas qu'il y a un malaise
aujourd'hui euh à gauche en général et
au sein des partis qui font vivre ce
courant de pensée en particulier
plusieurs initiatives sont en réflexion
l'alliance populaire autour du passé
socialiste des démarches d'ouverture
avec le Parti radical de gauche qui a
créé un pont avec un parti écologiste
Génération Écologie il y a des
recompositions avec le Front de Gauche
les écologies sont en pleine
recomposition aujourd'hui nous nous
travaillons également avec l'Union des
démocrates écologistes présidé par
Jean-Vincent placer qui siège dans le
groupe que je préside à la région
î-de-france voilà il y a un certain
nombre de d'initiatives qui contribue à
alimenter des dynamiques mais
aujourd'hui je crois que nous devons
nous interroger non pas en terme de
demande mais en terme d'offre
c'est aujourd'hui une nécessité absolue
nous devons à tout prix convaincre que
nous proposons un meilleur modèle et que
nous proposons des solution pour
répondre aux attentes et aux
préoccupations de la vie quotidienne je
crois que la gauche doit vraiment se
réinterroger aujourd'hui sur ce qui la
constitue pour la prochaine campagne des
présidentielles il y a eu un petit
changement qui a été voté à l'assemblée
décidé les députés qui ont décidé de
réduire la période d'égalité stricte
pour les temps de parole pour les
formations les plus petites formations
ça signifie sans doute moins d'accès aux
médias je voudrais avoir aussi votre
avis sur ce sujet-l auparavant je vais
vous laisser écouter un micro trottoir
nous sommes allés rencontrer quelques
habitants des ivelin pour leur demander
si justement les plus petits partis
avait assez accès pardon aux médias je
sais pas quand je regarde les médias à
la télé les grands BFM etélé c'est vrai
qu'il parle beaucoup des des grands
partis mais c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'il y a les les jeunes d'ailleurs qui
réclament un peu ce
cette chose là quoi que les petits
partis soient représentés c'est B c'est
représenté on leur donne moins la
possibilité de de passer dans dans les
grands médias notamment la télévision on
devrait les entendre plus je dirais
absolument pas bah comme petit parti
enfin à part St les partis écolo les
choses comme ça qu'on peut observer
enfin voilà parce que moi je m'y
intéresse sinon les autres partis je les
connais pas enfin je pourrais citer
aucun petit parti politique quoi non je
pense qu'on on offre le la position
médiatique au à ceux qui font le plus de
bruit donc en général c'est les plus
grands mais les petits non ils sont pas
représentés on voit pas assez les plus
petite formation le PRG par exemple on n
pas posé de question mais sur le Pr PRG
n pas une petite formation il compte
trois ministres deux groupes
parlementaires euh plusieurs milliers
d'élus c'est une vraie formation
républicaine encrée sur le territoire
mais on entend moins on identifie très
clairement le Parti socialiste
républain parce que le travail est
différent et puis parce qu'à un moment
donné oui peut-être que les médias on
une responsabilité mais mais moi j'ai
pas tendance à dire que c'est parce
qu'on fait 36 plateaux télé qui à un
moment donné la
visibilité où la force de conviction est
plus forte le FN n'a jamais été aussi
présent sur les audiences et n'a pas
remporté une seule région alors qu'en
lui on donné de une à trois régions
aujourd'hui heureusement qu'il n'en a
pris aucune maintenant la question qui
est posée avec la loi organique relative
à l'élection présidentielle qui a été
votée d'ailleurs à 12 voix à l'assemblée
à l'Assemblée nationale elle elle vise
également elle vise à ne plus considérer
l'égalité du temps de parole comme un
principe mais un principe d'équalité
d'équité pardon pour le temps de parole
donc moi je suis pas très à l'aise avec
ce dispositif là puisque il faut pour
être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle présenter 500 parrainages
et ce sésame là est déjà un sésame qui
permet d'acquérir une certaine
responsabilité dans la candidature il
faut aller chercher des maires des
conseillers régionaux des conseillers
départementaux donc le droit à l'égalité
du temps de parale me paraîté une mesure
juste et je trouve regrettable qu'elle
soit remise en cause aujourd'hui puis il
y a la question des primaires aussi
peut-être sur laquelle on peut réagir si
on parle campagne présidentielle il faut
une primaire à gauche aujourd'hui
justement est-ce que cette mesure sur le
temps de parole est-ce que les mesures
qui vont avec cette loi sur la
complexification rendue pour obtenir les
parmages n'est pas une façon de tuer
dans l'œuf les primaires les primaires
citoyennes même si elles se sont bien
tenu en 2011 et en 2012 à l'initiative
du Parti socialiste mais quand on voit
aujourd'hui la cacophonie à droite 13
voire 14 voir 15 candidat au moin il y
aura une primaire oui mais en fait je ne
suis pas certain qu'elle se Fass dans
des conditions qui permett vraiment un
débat et une construction et une
reconstruction de ce camp-là donc il
faut je crois que notre République
puisse permettre à toutes les
initiatives de de s'exprimer je suis pas
certain que pour l'opinion publique ce
soit un bon message qui soit envoyé une
primaire à gauche nécessaire oueu le PRG
a toujours été favorable au primaire il
a même en 2006 déposé une loi pour cela
elle n'a pas été votée elle n'a pas été
retenue aujourd'hui il y a un président
de la République il faut déjà savoir
s'il est candidat ou pas euh et une fois
sa candidature annoncée ou son absence
de candidature déclaré prendre notre
décisions je crois que s'il n'y a pas de
président sortant candidat le PRG peut
avoir toute sa place dans la primaire
justement françois Hollande candidat
pour 2017 deè micro trottoir
voilà est-ce qu'il doit être candidat
est-ce qu'il y a quelqu'un d'autre à
mettre je pense pas pourquoi on les
résultats sont pas satisfaisants
actuellement déjà ouis pourquoi c'est
bon parce que je pense que il y a pas
mieux actuellement pour tous Mo je pense
pas parce que bon il a rien fait on est
toujours à la galère et tout par rapport
le chômage il est augmenté il y a pas de
travail il y a rien du tout moi on a
essayé changer par rapport à Sarkozi
mais le meilleur mais je préfère Sarkozi
que François Hollande euh je pense que
oui pourquoi ben parce que c'est lui qui
a un bilan et donc avec ce bilan il doit
il doit se représenter pour avoir aès le
verdict de la de la population quoi non
pas du tout pourquoi
pas du tout il doit pas se
représenter pas du tout c'est ce qui
revient le plus souvent malgré tout oui
ou c'est un petit peu compliqué parce
qu'on leur demande pas s'ils sont pro ou
antiollande on le demande même de donner
un avis sur le principe d'une
candidature et les réponses sont un
petit peu surprenant mais moins moins
grave que je pensais puisque certain
nombre considè qu'il lui revient
d'assumer le bilan qui est le sien et
donc
d'obligation consid cel comme
aujourd'hui il a mené un projet un bilan
et le temps du bilan et de l'expression
de ce bilan viendra et on verra que des
choses ont été faites néanmoins la crise
sociale et la crise liée à l'emploi est
profonde et l'incompréhension des
Français sur ce sujetl est totale et je
crois que on a échoué aujourd'hui sur
sur ce chantier là et on a échoué à
expliquer aux Français aussi l'état de
la France tel qu'il était en 2012 et on
doit V globalement vous en êtes
satisfait il y a plusieurs ministres des
réalités gouvernementales qui font
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des choses euh à
valoriser dans ce bilan il y a un
certain nombre de de de choses qui
méritent d'être soulignées partagé avec
les Français sur l'égalité hommes-femmes
sur les nouveaux droits sur les
questions de société sur l'aide aux
entreprises sur la protection des
salariés euh des choses ont été mises en
œuvre et euh aujourd'hui ne sont pas ou
sont mal portés ce qu'on entend le plus
souvent c'est euh ces derniers mois la
question de la déchéance de la
nationalité par exemple on voit qu'une
ministre doit démissionner pour ne pas
porter ce ce texte et finalement le
texte ne sera jamais présenté il y a la
question de la loi de travail du travail
qui est actuellement discuté aussi euh
ça ça écorne aussi l'image de la gauche
globalement et du gouvernement
manifestement il y a eu quelques petits
soucis de séquençage sur sur ce projet
lié à la déchéance de nationalité même
si moi j'ai en souvenir ce très beau
discours prononcé au Congrès de
Versailles qui euh rassemblait
l'ensemble de la représentation
nationale et je crois que les primaires
à droite euh pour revenir euh là-dessus
sont venus parasiter un sujet qui aurait
dû être euh situé au-dessus et qui
aurait le parti et partisane et je crois
que la fonction présidentielle n'a pas
été respectée dans ce cadre là que les
parlementaires de droite du Sénat n'ont
pas jouer le jeu et que nous aurions dû
avoir ce projet de loi porté en congrès
car les parlements enfin les chambres
avaient fait leur travail et pour des
raisons liées à cette primaire interne à
droite cette réponse certes symbolique
mais forte au niveau de la du modèle de
notre nation à défendre n'a pas pu être
mené à son terme vous êtes conseiller
régional vous êtes aussi conseiller
spécial de la ministre de la Fonction
publique quel est votre rôle alors déjà
profiter de l'occasion qui m'est donné
pour le pour saluer enfin la ministre et
puis lui témoigner de ma reconnaissance
de m'avoir sollicité pour occuper auprès
d'elle cette fonction conseiller
spécial ve dire ce que ça veut dire je
suis le conseiller de la ministre et je
l'accompagne dans un certain nombre de
ses
réflex j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec elle
sur les problématiques li au dialogue
social NOTAM en amont des questions
liées au dégel du point d'indice
concernant le salaire des fonctionnaires
et j'ai Vitu un travail particulier à
ces côtés il m'est difficile d'en parler
puisque la RG républicaine veut qu'un
conseiller de ministres ne s'exprime pas
sur les missions qui sont les siennes
mais sachez que ce ministère est est
tenu par une ministre convaincu engagé
qui a à cœur de défendre une fonction
publique aujourd'hui modernisée et
renouvelée est-ce que c'est une fonction
que vous préférez à celle de conseiller
régional ou à celle d'élu alors il y a
le métier qui est conseiller spécial et
il y a la fonction le mandat qui est
celui de conseiller régional les deux
les deux se complètent c'est de la
politique mais je je je vis une belle
période d'épanouissement avec ce métier
de conseiller spécial auprès d'an
Girardin qui peut aussi paraître comme
un rebond après l'échec aux élections
municipales parce que vous avez étéouis
alors je souhaite pas je pas pour tous
les politiques il y aurait jamais assez
de place en conseil en cabinet
ministériel mais non puisque ma
reconversion professionnelle avait été
faite j'avais fait le choix d'ouvrir une
boîte de conseil de faire du conseil et
de la formation de l'aide à la prise de
décision publique et j'ai eu la chance
d'ê appelé c'est une responsabilité
auprès du ministre qu'on refuse pas mais
non je ne crois pas puisque on sera
vraiment très nombreux en cabinet
ministériel si ça devait être le cas
voilà on parle tout de même de de
carrière vous avez été élu maire en 2008
battu par 85 voies en 2014 au dernier
scrutinci me rappel voilà c'est j'allais
vous demander vous l'avez digéré cette
défaite visiblement pas tout à fait non
alors il y a plusieurs étapes c'est que
vous après la défaite vous savez pas que
vous traversez une période de dépression
en fait et c'est une fois que vous en
êtes sorti vous savez que c'est ça et ça
dure 6 mois plêtre plus pour d'autres
moins pour certains moi il m'a fallu 6
mois pour dépasser le stade de la colère
de la renue et aujourd'hui nous sommes
dans une phase de reconstruction de
l'opposition comme nous le sommes
d'ailleurs à la région Île-de-France
nous travaillons nous avons un groupe de
SEP élus nous portons un certain nombre
de valeurs nous avons aussi des
réalisation et un bilan que nous ne
souhaitons pas voir sacrifié sous le
prétexte de l'alternance mais nous
sommes prêts à soutenir chaque
initiative bonne qui nous sera présenter
néanmoins il est vrai que l'exercice
démocratique aujourd'hui à carrière
spisi est compliqué et euh nous avons dû
engager un certain nombre de procédures
auprès du Tribunal adistratif simplement
pour faire valoir les droits de
l'opposition et moi je parle même pas de
la question de fond mais sur la forme
même de l'exercice du mandat vous avez
demandé dernièrement l'annulation de la
délibération relative au débat
d'orientation budgétaire aussi vous
pensez bien qu'on fait pas ça avec
plaisir annuler un débat d'orientation
budgétaire est un acte grave dans une
collectivité locale mais aujourd'hui ce
qui nous a été présenté ne constitu pas
des orientations budgétaires comme la
loi nôre l'impose aux exécutifs de
Collectiv local donc nous avons saisi le
sous-préfet il lui reviendra maintenant
de le
décider nous espérons qu'il va nous
suivre et si les réponses et les
motivations de la sous-préfecture ne
sont pas satisfaisantes en terme de
droit nous envisageons de porter
l'affaire au tribunal administratif on
parlait de vos différents mandats
différentes fonction peut-être sur votre
façon aussi de faire de de la politique
vous êtes très présent sur les réseaux
sociaux vous êtes un un élu 2.0 pas
autant que le mer de poiss manipestement
vous êtes en tout cas assez présent
entre entre les tweets et puis aussi les
communiqués qui sont assez assez assez
fréquents
c'est important pour vous d'exister
aussi de montrer ce que vous faites par
ce B là un élu il a la volonté de de
témoigner à travers différents sujets
mais aussi de faire partager et puis
d'être d'être entendu et les médias à
travers toutes leurs formes font partie
de ces relais là après les médias sont
assez intelligents pour layer ce qu'il
faut ce qu'il ne faut pas oui moi je
pense qu'il faut se saisir des médias
quand on a la chance d'avoir des médias
locaux nombreux indépendant il faut il
faut être à leur côté moi je suis prê là
dessus à assumer cette hyper
communication mais auprès des médias
auprès aujourd'hui des administrés
auprès des Franciliens on aborde les
sujets à travers des
problématiques très lié à la vie
quotidienne après des démarches même de
proximité physique t as parlé de sa vie
privée aussi quelque fois là quand on
est un homme public ou une femme
publique à tous les niveaux qu'on soit
on accepte forcément une forme de
transparence sur son patrimoine sur sa
richesse et donc forcément sur sa vie
privée toute façon les gens ne veulent
pas le savoir mais vous le demandent
donc à un moment donné à chacun de
trouver la limite parce que via Internet
notamment en 2006 vous avez vous faites
partie de ces élus qui ont fait leur
commun out aussi ouais j'ai simplement
répondu à une question des médias en
fait j'ai attendu qu'on pose la question
à partir du moment où je jou le jeu de
la presse j'ai répondu à la question qui
m'était posé voilà de la même façon que
j'étais favorable au mariage pour tous
pas pour une pas par identité mais parce
que je considère que c'est l'égalité
pour tous et le même accès pour tous à
la loi j'ai fait le choix de me marier
parce que je considérais qu'au bout de
17 ans de vie commune ça pouvait seer
voilà il y a pas de raison que je
n'adopte pas moi aussi les codes d'une
société quand elles sont autorisées voà
et quelque fois ça a aussi une incidence
ensuite sur les campagnes politique
parce que en 2012 pendant les
législatives il y a aussi des insultes à
caractère homophobe qui vous ont visé
micipale 2014 municipale également
comment vous l'avez vécu toute cette
période là 2012 je l'ai pris comme comme
faisant partie du jeu même si je la
condamne sur le fond mais une élection
national voilà
m au municipal j'étaé profondément
blessé profondément blessé par que les
attaques étaient sales
euh personnelles et mon véritablement
atteintes je le dis sincèrement puisque
pendant l'exercice de mon mandat
municipal il ne m'a jamais été fait ce
reproche bien au contraire les carirrois
me demandaient à voir mon conjoint me
demander à ne pas avoir là-dessus tabou
et j'ai toujours fait le choix de ne pas
mélanger et de la même façon que j'avais
pas fait de junisme quand j'étais élu à
32 ans de ne pas mélanger de pas faire
de de mise en œuvre de politique
publique communautarie sauf si elle si
elles étaient lié au à l'égalité des
droits la lutte contre le sida la lutte
pour l'égalité hom femmes et cetera et
là je me suis retrouvé S avec des
papiers collés dans les arrêts de bus
des tracs distribués à des enfants à la
sortie des écoles voilà et moi j'ai très
très mal vécu cette campagne en général
et en particulier pour cela et ça laisse
des trace moi ça je reste blessé c'est
j'ai rarement atteint en politique
rarement secoué mais là j'ai considéré
que la ligne rouge avait été franchie et
je regrette qu'on nit pas pu identifier
l'auteur de ces tractes anonyme mais de
la même façon pendant le mandat où j'ai
été insulté et attaqué pendant la
campagne et là l'auteur des faits a été
condamné à TR mois 3 mois de prison avec
surc et je pense qu'il doit pas y avoir
là-dessus de de laisser faire et de la
même façon que j'invite moi toutes les
victimes de violence à faire valoir leur
droits les élus ont l'obligation je
considère morale à se défendre là-dessus
quand ils font l'objet d'attaque parce
que si nous nous ne le faisons pas
comment la personne isolée pourrait-elle
oser le faire voilà je crois que
là-dessus il faut il faut se
une dernière question la suite pour vous
en politique c'est quoi redevenir maire
par la suite comment vous voyez
l'évolution décide ça tout alorsus j'ai
aussi évolué je pouvais en avoir besoin
pour ma reconstruction personnelle
aujourd'hui je ne serai candidat en 2020
carère sous préis que si j'en ai
véritablement envie et si je me sens
prêt à pouvoir proposer au carura un
programme innovant une équipe renouvelée
et surtout que les conditions d'une
nouvelle rencontre soit créée comme en
2008 2014 j'ai échoué j'en tire les
leçons personnelles programmatique et
politique j'assume ma part d'erreur mais
je considère que le match est pas
complètement joué même
si je prends conscience aujourd'hui de
l'importance de la vie privée de
professionnel avant tout merci merci à
[Musique]
vous